[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: Welcome
to rstudio::global.
Thank you so much for tuning in.
I'm going to talk
today about the things
that we can learn about ggplot2
from our data visualization
mishaps.
So if you have spent much
time visualizing data,
you have probably ended
up with some plots
that did not go to plan.
Maybe you had lots of
overlapping blue hexagons
or text that took
up the entire area
of the plot or giant hairballs.
My name is Kara Woo.
And I'm one of the maintainers
of the accidental aRt Twitter
account and I'm a
contributor to ggplot2 also.
So I've seen a lot of plots
that have gone totally wrong.
The accidental aRt account
exists to showcase these plots.
To showcase the plots
gone beautifully wrong,
the things that didn't work out
but looked cool nonetheless.
And I've seen also plots
that just straight up
flopped in sometimes
really subtle or hard
to diagnose ways.
And so there's this whole
spectrum of messed up plots
that I've seen, and
I know that these
can be really frustrating.
But they can also be
an opportunity for us
to create better
plots and to deepen
our understanding
of the tools that we
use to create those plots.
So if you're like me, then when
you create a plot like the ones
that I've showed, you likely go
to a place like Stack Overflow
to find someone with
a similar problem.
Find a hopeful solution
and bring that over
into your code to hopefully fix
the problem that you've had.
And that's great and
that's totally legitimate.
I'm going to argue
though, that when
you get that working
solution, it's
worth taking the time to think
about how that solution fits
in to the conceptual
model of ggplot2.
My feeling is that by
examining these messed up plots
that our mistakes generate
and how we fix them,
we can deepen our understanding
of ggplot2's philosophy
to create better visualizations
faster and more reliably.
So what do I mean by
ggplot2's philosophy?
ggplot2 is a data
visualization package
that embodies a whole
theory of visualization
called the layered
grammar of graphics,
which is based on
Leland Wilkinson's
Grammar of Graphics.
But it has some specific
things that are tailored
to its implementation in R.
Lots of visualization
software gives you
a bunch of different
charts to choose from.
So you have your pie charts
and your scatter plots,
and your line charts,
and your bar charts
and you take the
end result that you
want to achieve and
sort of work backwards
to fit your data into it.
ggplot2 is not like this.
ggplot2 is a more
data first approach
to building
visualizations, starting
with principles of
essentially a grammar for how
to convey data in visual form.
So when we speak or
write, we don't normally
start with a sentence
structure that we
want to use and then fit our
message into that structure.
Instead we start
with some idea and we
use our knowledge of grammar
and syntax and vocabulary
to craft the message we
want to express that idea.
And that is very analogous
to how ggplot2 works.
ggplot2 lets us express our
data in visual forms that
might be totally
novel and not fit
into common bar
charts and line charts
and common types
of visualizations.
This gives us a really flexible
tool and a really powerful
tool, that we can use to
create the intentional aRt,
like you see on the
slide, which was built
with Danielle Navarro's flametree
package, which itself uses
ggplot2.
So having this
flexibility, gives us
a lot of power and control,
and it also opens up room
for mistakes and for things
to not always work out
the way we had in mind,
the first time around.
There are certain
foibles and mistakes
that come up a lot with
ggplot2 that demonstrate
pretty common misunderstandings
of how ggplot2,
the package works
and that's what
I'm going to talk about today.
The first one that we're
going to talk about
are mapping mishaps.
These don't have to do
with geographical maps.
What we're talking
about here is mapping
visual properties in the plot
to variables in our data.
In the parlance of ggplot2
this these mappings
are called aesthetics.
And they're really at the
heart of ggplot2's grammar
of graphics.
So let's take this plot.
This is a plot of
flipper and bill
length for different species
of penguins in Antarctica.
And in this plot, we have
several different aesthetics.
We have position along
the x-axis, which
corresponds to flipper length.
We have position along
the y-axis, which
corresponds to bill length.
And then we have
both color and shape,
which correspond to
the penguin species.
So one thing that we might want
to do with a plot like this
is label these
different clusters.
We have sort of well-isolated
clusters of these data points
and maybe instead of the
legend at the bottom,
we want to label those
clusters with which species
they correspond to.
And what someone will
often do to achieve
this is add a layer 2
the plot, where they
map the text that
they want to appear
to the x and y positions,
where they want to place it.
So here we have that x
equals 195 and y equals 55,
we're placing the label chinstrap.
And you can see that,
that does work in that it
places text on the plot.
If we look closely though,
it doesn't actually
look that good.
So it's pretty subtle
in this example
but the quality of the text
is a little bit pixelated.
It doesn't look as good
as the points and lines
that are around it.
And if we were running
this code live,
it would actually be a
little bit slow to plot.
Now like I said it's a pretty
subtle change or subtle issue
but we actually get a lot of
ggplot2 issues opened because
of this specific
thing, where people
run into with their own plots
that the plot is really slow,
that the text looks really bad.
And they come to us to say
is this a bug in ggplot2
like it, why does
it look so bad?
We can illustrate what's
going on here another way
by using the ggrepel package,
which will ensure that text
on the plot does not overlap.
And when we do that, we can see
that we actually haven't just
put a single label on the plot.
We've put this whole giant
starburst of the same text
repeated hundreds of times.
What's going on here
is that we've actually
written our label the
same number of times
as there are rows
in our data set.
In this case, 344 times.
By putting the text label
that we want inside this aes
function, where aes
stands for aesthetic,
we've declared a
mapping between our data
and the label causing that
label to repeat as many times
as there are data points.
So that's not great
and we can avoid this
by actually using a
different function called
annotate, which is designed to
put labels on plots just once.
So it's designed to do exactly
what we want to do, just
stick that label on
there once, not map it
to the underlying data.
So we tell annotate that we
want to place a text annotation.
Again give it the
position and the label
and it places that
text on the plot for us
and when we zoom in,
it looks much better.
It would be much
faster to plot as well.
So that was mapping
mishaps, where
we misapplied these
aesthetic mappings
between visual elements
of the plot and our data.
The next common mix up is
what I'll call scale snafus.
In ggplot2 scales convert
values from the data space
to the aesthetic space.
So with our aesthetics
that we just talked about,
we declared a mapping between
visual elements of the plot
and values in the data--
shape to species for instance.
The scale controls how those
data points get translated
into what we see on the plot.
We're going to talk about
coordinate systems too,
which I would draw the
axes and panels in the plot
and generally kind of set up
the 2D environment of the plot.
So most plots that
including the one that we're
using for our example here, use
a simple Cartesian coordinate
system but other plots
can use for example
like a geographical coordinate
system or polar coordinate
system in the case
of pie charts.
So let's return to our flipper
and bill length visualization.
And this time in addition
to the data points,
I've added the smooth
conditional means
for each species.
Now let's say that we
want to zoom in this plot
to highlight one species
and sort of focus
our attention in on just one
of these areas of the plot.
There are two ways that
we can accomplish this.
One is by setting
limits on the scale.
Here we're setting the x minimum
to 200 and the x maximum--
we just let be whatever
it normally was.
And then the other way that
we can zoom in this plot
is by setting limits on
the coordinate system.
Again, setting the x minimum
to 200 and letting the x
max be whatever it is.
When we limit the scale, this
is the plot that we end up with.
But when we limit the
coordinate system,
it actually looks
quite different.
The data looks the same.
The individual
points are the same
but the statistical summary
looks drastically different
and that is because when
we set the scale limits,
any data that's
outside of those limits
will by default be
converted to NAs.
And that this scale
transformation
happens before any
statistical summaries.
So before we calculate what
those smooth lines and error
bands look like that data has
already been converted to NAs.
The coordinate system
on the other hand,
when you set limits there, it
really just zooms in the plot.
So all the other data that
was originally present
is still getting
used, even though you
can't see it on the plot.
So in the first plot, where we
set the limits on the scale,
statistical summaries look
different because they're
based on just the
few data points that
are visible for the
species in red and purple.
In the second plot,
though you can
imagine that all the rest
of the data is still there
and it's still getting
used and those smooth lines
are extending out towards,
where the rest of the data is.
So this is clearly a case where
the different ways of setting
these limits have
major implications
for the statistical
summaries that we're actually
displaying on the plot.
And it's important to know this.
So ggplot2 does
alert us to this fact
and if we return to the code
that generated these plots,
you can actually see that the
former version will warn you
about what's going on.
It says "removed the 192 rows
containing non-finite values".
So we've gotten this
Warning message.
But it is at times easy to
gloss over these messages
or ignore them.
And so it's useful to know how
scales and coordinates handle
data, that's out of bounds.
The last type of ggplot2 mishap
that I'm going to talk about
are issues with
themes, theme threats.
Now ggplot2 theme
system is not strictly
part of the grammar of
graphics because it really
controls all of the non-data
aspects of the plot,
whereas the grammar mostly
deals with how we translate
our data into visual form.
But the theme system
is really important
because it is how you customize
a plot to look exactly how you
want it, all the way up from
the text font and the background
color down to small details
like the length of the ticks
on the axes for example.
There are dozens
and dozens of things
that you can customize
about plots in ggplot2
but it would be really
cumbersome to have
to specify every single one
of those every single time.
So ggplot2 comes with
a set of default themes
that are built in, that you
can use and a system for theme
elements to inherit
their values and how
they look from other
aspects of the theme.
So let's look at an example.
In our theme hierarchy
of different elements
that you can customize text is
one that's way up at the top.
In theory, this applies to all
the text elements of the plot.
So if we look again
at our Penguin plot,
this plot has a number of
different text elements
it has title it has axis
titles and axis text.
It has a legend, which has
some text on it as well.
So all of these are within
the umbrella of text.
If you wanted to,
for example, set
the font of all the
text on this plot,
you would want to do it
up at that text level,
rather than having to say I
want the title to be this font
and the axis labels to
be this font and so on.
At the next level of the
hierarchy in this example,
is axis.text.
So we went from text
down to just the text
that labels the axes.
That's everything
that is outlined
in blue on this slide,
all the axis.text elements
and in this plot, we have axes
on the left, right and bottom.
At the next level of
the theme hierarchy,
there's axis.text.x
and axis.text.y.
So this allows us
to, for example,
customize the y-axis, while
leaving the x-axis alone
and vice versa.
And there's actually
one more level.
axis.text.x.bottom, axis.text.x.top,
axis.text.y.left
and axis.text.y.right.
(Try saying that 10
times fast!) where
we can customize axes
for potentially one
side of the plot
but not the other.
So these axes can be on the
bottom or the top or the left
and the right or some
combination thereof
and you might want to have
really fine-grained control
over exactly which
customizations you're making.
So this level allows
us to do that.
So let's return to our plot.
So again, we're looking at
these penguin measurements.
And this time, I've
added a second axis
on the right hand side of the
plot, that just duplicates
the axis on the left hand side.
So they're exactly the same.
And now let's say that we
wanted to customize the labels
on our two y axes.
So that they're maybe rotated
90 degrees and right justified.
So we might write
something like this
to customize both
of these axes, where
we're setting axis.text.y
to angle equals 90,
hjust (horizontal
justification) equals 1
and since we want to apply
this to both of our y axes,
this seems like the
logical way to do it.
But when we look at the plot
something is not quite right.
The rotation has taken effect
but the justification has not.
So only on the
left hand side are
axis labels right justified.
On the right hand
side they don't match.
So why would one
of these changes
take effect but
not the other one?
And the reason for this has
to do with the base theme
that I'm using.
So I built the theme
for these plots
on the default ggplot2
theme, theme_grey.
And if we printed out the whole
theme, it would be super long.
So we're not going
to look at all of it.
But I've just put on the
slide the parts of it
that have to do with axis text.
You can see that theme_grey
sets the margins
and the justification
of axis.text.y
and then it actually
adjusts those details
for axis.text.y.right
And in particular theme_grey
is setting the justification
of text in axis.text.y.right
to zero, corresponding
to a left justified text.
This brings us to
the crucial piece
of the theme system,
which is that when
you're customizing
theme elements,
the most specific element wins.
If the theme that you're
using sets a specific element
like the justification
of axis.text.y.right,
then if you want
to change it, you
need to edit that very
specific element and not
any of the ones above it.
So in our case theme_grey
sets the justification but not
the angle of axis.text.y.right.
So when we change axis.text.y,
the justification
that we provided gets
overwritten by the theme
that we're using.
This is something that has
thrown off so many people.
It's thrown off me.
It's thrown off other
contributors to ggplot.
It comes up all of
the time because it
is a subtle and
slightly confusing
aspect of how this
theme inheritance works.
But when you think
about the fact
that it's working by
specificity and not
by the order in
which you provide
customizations to the theme.
It does make sense.
So to get a working
plot, we would
need to edit axis.text.y.right
like this.
So instead of setting our
customizations to the axis.text.y
element, where they'll
be overwritten by the theme
that we're using.
We customize axis.text.y.left
and axis.text.y.right
and that makes sure that our
customizations get applied
the way we want them to.
And now everything
looks good on the plot.
These two axes are
looking exactly the same
on the left and the right.
So let's recap the ggplot2
mishaps we've talked about.
We have mapping mishaps,
where we accidentally
map the data to a single
visual element over,
and over, and over again.
We have scale snafus,
which is where
we have two different
ways of setting
the boundaries of a plot, where
one of them discards data.
One of them does not.
And this can affect the
statistical summaries
that are shown on the plot.
And we have theme
threats, where we
try to customize the plot at
a higher level of the theme
hierarchy that then gets
overridden by a more
specific theme customization.
We haven't gotten into all of
the components of the grammar.
We haven't talked about stats,
geoms, position adjustments
and that much detail,
but if you really
want to get deep into the
understanding of how ggplot2
works and all of the
parts of the grammar
that we haven't covered,
you should definitely
check out the ggplot2 book.
There's a chapter in
there specifically,
about mastering the
grammar and it will really
help you build the
solid foundation
for understanding all of
these different components
of ggplot2.
So I want to leave you with one
last piece of accidental aRt.
It's one of my
favorite patterns that
comes up over and over again
on the accidental aRt Twitter
page.
This sort of weird
geometric pattern
that you often see in maps.
So here we're taking
data on states,
trying to plot it on a map but
it's gotten totally messed up.
So if you don't know
what's causing this error.
See if you can find
out a fix to it
and then think about whether
that fix tells you anything
about how ggplot2 works.
For the purposes of this slide,
I've not included the full code
on the display.
But if you want to see the
full code for this plot
as well as all of the
other visualizations
that were included in this
talk, have a look at this URL
and thank you so
much for tuning in.
Good luck with your
future ggplots and I
hope that you have
enjoyed the talk.